so with the popular response that we got
from yesterday's video about the best
boobs in Marvel Comics I figured we need
to do something for the ladies we got to
do something for the girls we got to
show women that men have something to
offer in Marvel Comics there's something
out there for everyone and so in this
video we're going to be talking about
the five best bulges in Marvel Comics
so starting things off on our
the number five spot is Colossus and I
imagine most people would think you'd
have to be on this list somewhere with
good reason because it's clear from this
picture that Colossus is definitely one
of the heavy hitters on the x-men team
coming in at number four is Wolverine
and while Logan is a short guy he makes
up for it with the Bulls that clearly
ranks among one of the best in Marvel
Comics rounding out our list in the
number three spot is Captain America
boasting a bulge worthy of America it's
clear that the Super Soldier Serum
upgraded more than just Steve Rogers
physique here at number two on our list
is apocalypse from the Ultimate Universe
I know this kind of comes out of left
field for some people but it's clear
from this bulge that where Marvel says
that apocalypse can control the atomic
structure of his body but they were
lying and coming in at the number one
spot on our list is none other than
Galactus now Galactus keeps his Bulls
pretty well hidden under his apron but
let's be honest ladies anyone that
stands 2,000 feet tall it's gonna have a
pretty massive bulge with that being
said we're gonna go ahead and bring this
one to an end just keep in mind guys
this was a one-off we're probably never
gonna touch back on this again it was
just a way to have fun but that being
said I will catch you guys later peace
be sure to follow me on Twitter there
you can keep up with all the updates
from comics explained and talk to me
directly